[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous heureux de
vous accueillir aujourd'hui pour cette
nouvelle conférence que nous avons placé
sous le thème de la transition
écologique enjeux et opportunités
nous accueillerons dans quelques
instants jean marc jancovici associés de
la société carbone 4
qui ne donnera des détails sur ce sujet
mais auparavant je souhaite partager
avec vous quelques éléments
d'introduction le réchauffement
climatique est devenu pour chacun et
chacune d'entre nous un enjeu dont nous
ressentons les effets dans notre vie
quotidienne
pourtant la température à la surface de
la terre a toujours varié pour des
raisons naturelles mais l'observation
sur très longue période nous montre un
emballement incontestable ces 50
dernières années
ironie de l'histoire ce sont des
chercheurs américains qui dans les
années 70 ont tiré pour la première fois
la sonnette d'alarmé
et c'est sous l'administration carter
qui commanda le premier rappeur le
rapport charney qui pour la première
fois démontré un lien entre les
émissions de co2 et le réchauffement
climatique
ainsi la concentration de co2 dans
l'atmosphère provoquant l'effet de serre
à l'origine du réchauffement a été
multiplié par deux depuis l'ère
préindustrielle et deux tiers de ce
réchauffement est imputable aux seules
50 dernières années
dès lors il s'agit de comprendre et
d'agir sur les causes de cette hausse
exponentielle des émissions de co2 et
plus largement des gaz à effet de serre
en voilà trois que nous pouvons observer
assez facilement sur les 50 dernières
années une population mondiale multiplié
par presque trois une création de
richesse x 30 et par conséquent des
besoins en énergie et en ressources
naturelles en très forte hausse pour
éviter des conséquences irréversibles
sur les écosystèmes naturels et la vie
humaine
il est désormais impératif de tenir les
engagements des accords de paris visant
à limiter la hausse des températures à
moins de 2 degrés par rapport à l'ère
préindustrielle nous connaissons la voie
à suivre pour décarbonés notre économie
et atteindre la neutralité carbone
tout d'abord agir sur le mix de
production d'énergie adapter nos modes
de production pour les rendre moins
énergivores repenser la mobilité est
protégé par une utilisation raisonnée
nos ressources naturelles
compris le réchauffement climatique
étant devenu un risque existentiel la
transition écologique est désormais une
nécessité
merci jean marc jancovici d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui vous êtes associé de la
société carbone 4
fondée en 2007 dont vous êtes toujours
le dirigeant il vous est également
membre du haut conseil pour le climat
organisme indépendant installé par le
président de la république en 2018 alors
tout d'abord vous voulez aborder un
certain nombre de questions avec vous et
je vais commencer par la première
comment définissez-vous la transition
écologique c'est tout le problème
il n'y a pas de définition normative de
la transition écologique un rendement
sur un placement tous vos clients savent
très bien ce que c'est c'est la quantité
d'argent qui vous reste à la fin de
l'année par rapport au capital investi
au début de l'année il ya une définition
tout à fait normal type c se mesure on
peut le mesurer en valeur absolue ou en
pourcentage ça se pentifie donc
donc on peut comparer et c'est la
transition écologique a pas de
définition normative donc les uns vont
vous dire
les choses de manière qualitative d'une
certaine façon par exemple les nations
unies vous dise le développement durable
c'est un développement qui n'empêche pas
les générations futures de satisfaire à
leurs besoins tout en permettant aux
générations précédentes présente pardon
de satisfaire les leurs vous voyez bien
qu'on n'a toujours pas donné de
définition normative parce qu'un besoin
c'est quoi est-ce que j'ai besoin
d'avoir trois voitures une voiture ils
dominent voiture un vélo est ce que j'ai
besoin de prendre un taxi volant ou par
voilà donc a besoin on sait pas le
définir de manière normative vous avez
dans la définition des nations unies 17
objectifs différents qui se marchent sur
les pieds
donc la transition écologique en fait
vous vous rendez compte quand vous
regardez un peu dans les faits chacun
voit midi à sa porte et que c'est très
très difficile d'avoir une définition
partagée
si on se limite au sujet qui m'est plus
familier j'ai envie de dire savoir
l'énergie et le changement climatique
même dans ce domaine les pays ne
partagent pas les objectifs par exemple
en allemagne
le premier objectif de la transition
c'est d'essais nucléaires en france sont
des hybrides
on nous dit qu'on va faire les deux à la
fois en grande bretagne c'est clairement
baissé de co2 et le nucléaire est un
allié dont vous voyez il n'y a pas de
définition objective de la transition
on peut donner quand même un impératif à
respecter en ce qui concerne la question
climatique et l'impératif à respecter il
vient tous est tout bêtement de physique
il se trouve que le dioxyde de carbone
qui est donc un gaz à effet de serre
émis par les hommes a la particularité
d'être chimiquement inaltérable temps
qui n'est dans l'atmosphère il se trouve
par ailleurs que ce gaz est la propriété
d'intercepter les infrarouges terrestre
de grande longueur d'onde qui sont émis
par la surface et donc plus vous
rajoutez du dioxyde de carbone dans
l'atmosphère est plus l'atmosphère est
opaque au rayonnement infrarouge émis
par la planète et donc plus la surface
se réchauffe
donc la solution au changement
climatique commence par un simple preuve
de robinet il faut que ce qu'on rajoute
dans l'atmosphère ne soit pas supérieur
à ce que l'atmosphère est capable
d'évacuer vers le sol dans les océans ou
dans la photosynthèse
la de la biosphère et donc il ya une des
fils il ya au moins une épreuve
obligatoire j'ai envie de dire dans la
transition qui bien que c'est une
épreuve obligatoire c'est pas la seule
qui est d'arriver à baisser les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre des
hommes jusqu'au moment où les puits sont
capables de reprendre la totalité de
ceux qui rentrent dans l'atmosphère
c'est ce qu'on appelle la neutralité
carbone donc il ya au moins un élément
obligatoire j'ai envie de dire dans la
transition vue de ma fenêtre qui est de
parvenir à cette fameuse neutralité
carbone et je finirai en disant qu'il
est une voiture balai qui est que si on
n'est pas capable de le faire
volontairement de toute façon la
finitude des stocks fossiles fait qu'on
y arrivera involontairement à un moment
ou à un autre et les régulations
involontaire ça ressemble beaucoup plus
au co vide que ça ne ressemble aux
choses organisé et sympathique d'accord
première donc effectivement la
transition écologique est une nécessité
aujourd'hui on le voit bien tous alors
pourquoi si important aussi on évoque
souvent cette barre des deux degrés
pourquoi est il si important de rester
en dessous des crises est convenu un
objectif politique la science ne vous
dis pas à 1.80 18 degrés tout va bien et
à 2,01 degrés c'est l'apocalypse c'est
pas du tout comme ça que ça marche il ya
un premier point qu'il faut garder en
tête c'est qu'une élévation de
température pour la planète dans son
ensemble ça ne provoque pas des dégâts
qui sont proportionnelles à l'élévation
vous savez dans le monde économique on a
tendance à penser par exemple dans votre
métier je place un million je gagne 100
mille euros je place 2 millions gillet
200 vidéos ou mieux encore seulement en
ce qui concerne l'élévation de
température c'est pas du tout comme ça
que ça marche
2° c'est pas deux fois plus grave que 20
degrés et ce sera peut-être mille fois
dix mille fois plus grave qu'un degré et
3° sastre est un million de fois plus
grave que un degré d'accord c'est
d'accord il ya quelque chose qu'il faut
qui est très utile en terme de parts
laisse notre propre corps si notre
propre corps et une élévation de la
température interne de 20° bon on est
mal foutu éventuellement on va pas au
bureau le matin au travail le matin puis
ça s'arrête là si on a une élévation de
température interne de 5 degrés c'est
pas cinq jours de bureau aura tant
d'efforts en ce qui concerne la planète
dans son ensemble c'est ça qu'il faut
garder aussi en tête c'est que les
dégâts augmentent très très vite avec
l'élévation de température à 5 degrés de
hausse en un siècle
toujours pour fixer les idées il ya
entre un et deux millions
holmes qui vivront sur terre dans des
zones dans lesquelles aujourd'hui il est
impossible de vivre les conditions
extérieures en termes de température une
température et d'humidité font que les
gens n'ont juste pas vivre quelque part
d'individus
bon alors politiquement on a fait le
choix de s'arrêter à deux degrés mais on
aurait pu faire le choix de s'arrêter à
1,8 à 2 degrés il faut bien voir que
tous les coraux sont morts ou à peu près
sur terre une bonne partie des forêts
françaises aura déjà disparu par stress
hydrique ou incendie n'est pas en train
de parler des broutilles maintenant
quand on regarde l'inertie du système il
faut bien voir que les 1,5 degré sont
déjà embarqué dans nos émissions passées
donc ça de toute façon on a déjà perdu 5
v et pour se limiter à 2 degrés il faut
que les émissions planétaires baisse de
l'équivalent d'un kobe de
supplémentaires tous les ans c'est à
dire qu'il faudrait qu'elle baisse de 5%
par an à partir de maintenant tous les
ans pour les décennies qui viennent
d'ici à ce que vous mourriez on va dire
d'ici à ce que vos enfants
il faut baisser de 5% par an 5 % c'est
la baisse qu'on va avoir en 2020 grâce
entre guillemets locaux vides et que ces
salles ordre de grandeur de ce qu'il
faut qu'on atteigne pour se limiter à 2
degrés sachant que si on ne se limite
pas à deux degrés je reviens tout à
l'heure les conséquences du changement
climatique et d'autres conséquences
environnementales se charge de toutes
façons de faire en sorte que l'activité
humaine soit très fortement attaquées
par les conditions environnementales
d'accord alors par conséquent je reviens
à ce que vous disiez sur la nécessité de
baisser en absolu les émissions de
carbone et du coup nous ont tant
qu'investisseur comment favoriser l
investissement pourrait favoriser cette
transition écologique
alors il ya une chose très désagréable à
comprendre pour les investisseurs que
vous êtes c'est que quand vous regardez
ce qui a fait l'économie monde moderne
en fait l'économie moderne est une
économie de machines la veste vous
portez a été fabriqué par une machine
il en va de même du micro dans lequel
vous parlez de la tablette que vous avez
dans votre main de la montre que vous
portez au poignet de la moquette sur
laquelle nous sommes installés du siège
sur lequel je suis posée de la caméra
qui le filme de tous les revêtements de
sols sur lesquels j'ai marché dans la
rue en venant jusqu'à jusqu'à vous et
c'est ce que je vais manger à midi
parmi les hausses ce soir donc en gros
le monde dans lequel nous vivons est un
monde dans lequel tout ce qui nous
entoure est fait par des machines
et il se trouve que ces machines
utilisent essentiellement dans le monde
des combustibles fossiles
donc en fait les combustibles fossiles
et des croquettes pour machines c'est
comme ça qu'il faut voir la chose et
l'efficacité et le déplacement de cette
énergie fossile dans autre chose ne peut
pas aller à la vitesse suffisante pour
qu'on garde le parc de machines
actuelles dans le monde dans un monde
qui se décline donc la première
conclusion qu'il faut avoir en tête
quand vous êtes un investisseur sait
qu'un monde qui vise les deux degrés et
un monde récessif
voilà c'est ça qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est un monde dans lequel on
est structurellement en récession ça
change un peu la donne par rapport au
monde au kenya
oui ça change beaucoup la donne est donc
ce que je suis en train de dire c'est
que un investisseur pris isolément peut
devenir 2° la totalité de la finance
prise dans sa globalité ne le peut pas
c'est juste impossible
à partir du moment où l'économie globale
est à 4 degrés tous les acteurs
financiers et consolidés ne peuvent pas
passer à 2 degrés c'est juste impossible
donc les donc certains investisseurs
peuvent tirer leur épingle du jeu
mais c'est dingue c'est un effet de
niche ça peut pas concerner tout le
monde et ça se fait avec des méthodes
qui permettent de comprendre à quelle
distance du problème sont les
sous-jacents c'est-à-dire les
entreprises ou les états qui émettent
les actions les obligations plus tous
les trucs très sophistiqué qu'on a fait
par dessus dans lesquels vous allez
investir à quelle distance et qui sont
du problème climatique donc il faut des
méthodes une métrologie particulière qui
permettent de comprendre à quelle
distance une activité donnée et du
problème climatique d'accord donc là
vous abordent la question peut-être de
la comptabilité carbone et la neutralité
carbone
donc comment définissez-vous cette
notion de neutralité carbone pour une
entreprise aujourd'hui
alors en ce qui concerne une entreprise
dire qu'elle devient neutre ça voudrait
dire qu'elle a été capable elle toute
seule dans son coin de s'abstraire d'un
problème climatique qui concerne
l'ensemble de l'activité humaine
c'est juste impossible si je prends
l'exemple de google par exemple qui a
dit qu'il était neutre
ça voudrait dire que tout d'un coup la
question des combustibles fossiles ne
peut plus impacté la quantité
d'ordinateurs qui sont nécessaires pour
que les clients utilisent google
la quantité d'ordinateurs qui est
nécessaire pour qu'il y ait des serveurs
google et mieux encore la quantité de
produits qu'on fabrique pour que google
puisse vente du ciblage publicitaire
parce que je rappelle que c'est avec ça
que google gagne de l'argent
vous comprenez bien que si je mets
demain matin une énorme contrainte sur
les combustibles fossiles
google peut avoir raconté ce qu'ils
voulaient sur leur prétendue neutralité
ils seront impactés de manière directe
par la contrainte donc la neutralité
d'une entreprise veut dire si on
comprend bien qu'elle s'est abstraite du
problème climatique et qu'elle a
supprimé sa dépendance aux combustibles
fossiles alors que quand vous regardez
sa chaîne de valeur c'est exactement
pareil qu'avant donc la neutralité des
entreprises aujourd'hui c'est juste un
tour de passe-passe basé sur une
comptabilité qui n'a pas de sens qui est
celle de la compensation
mais en fait vous ne vous êtes pas des
risques et aujourd'hui quand vous êtes
une entreprise et que vous dites que
vous êtes neutre ceux des risques et
pour une entreprise c'est contribuer à
la neutralité mondiale ce qui est tout à
fait différent d'accord je reviens de
tête sur le mix énergétique et quels
investissements sont souhaitables en
fait pour faire évoluer celui que serge
éthique vers quelque part cet objectif
de neutralité carbone
aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup des
évidemment d'énergies renouvelables très
vertueuse
qu'en est il
et quels sont les meilleurs
investissements aujourd'hui les énergies
renouvelables il faut bien voir que
avant d'être les énergies vers lesquels
nous allons peut-être c'est surtout les
énergies dont nous sommes sortis
l'humanité à fonctionner dans un mode
100 % renouvelable entre l'apparition
des hommes il ya quelques millions
d'années et il y a deux siècles donc
l'essentiel de l'histoire de nos
ancêtres s'est passé dans un monde 100 %
renouvelable ans n'était pas exactement
le monde dont on pense qu'elles ont
parié obtient pas de taxis volant et de
hockey google c'est un monde dans lequel
tout le monde était agriculteur quelques
un bûcheron et il y avait trois doubles
à la cour qu'ils pouvaient vivre sur la
productivité marginale j'ai envie de
dire de toute cette de toute cette
population pas très productive quand on
est sorti des énergies renouvelables de
passer aux énergies fossiles et c'est ce
qui a permis de mettre en route les
machines à vapeur puis les moteurs à
combustion interne qui ont démultiplié
par un facteur de plusieurs centaines
j'aime 6 par un facteur de chlore
centaine la puissance musculaire de
l'humanité donc aujourd'hui le parc de
machines à combustibles fossiles sur
lequel nous sommes assis dans le monde a
permis au pib mondial lettre x 200 par
rapport à 6 on avait juste conserver la
puissance musculaire de quelques
milliards d'hommes qui sont sur terre
pas une seconde les énergies
renouvelables dont nous sommes sortis
je rappelle vont permettre de remplacer
les combustibles fossiles au même niveau
de parc de machines pas une seconde
donc à mon 100% renouvelable peut y
retourner c'est un monde dans lequel le
pib mondial et / n'importe quoi entre 5
et 50
d'accord c'est un vrai décor c'est ça il
faut bien voir que par exemple quand
vous produisez de l'électricité solaire
ou éolienne vous avez besoin de dizaines
de centaines de fois plus de métal par
kilowattheure électrique produit que
quand vous utilisez un autre fossile ou
un mode nucléaire du reste c'est des
modes concentré et pilotable des
centaines de fois plus de métal des
milliers de fois plus d espace avec le
solaire jamais vous arriverez à
remplacer ce qu'on a aujourd'hui avec
les combustibles fossiles part de
l'éolien du solaire par une fois je veux
bien prendre si vous êtes un peu joueur
on va juste devant chez le notaire en
sortant d'ici je prends le pari on
l'enregistré évident que j'ai vu que je
gagne donc la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui on pense que les énergies
renouvelables
intéressante dans le monde financier
c'est d'abord parce que ça offre des
revenus garantis sur le long terme donc
ça c'est un truc que vous adorez à
partir du moment où vous promet 5 à 10%
alors maintenant que pour ça on les a
plus mais 5% sur capitaux investis de
façon garantit aux frais du contribuable
sur 20 ans vont précipiter dessus
surtout au moment où le bund allemand et
un rendement négatif donc il ya juste
pas photo les énergies renouvelables
aujourd'hui en fait c'est des
dispositifs qui sont produits avec un
monde qui est sous perfusion fossiles
c'est à dire que les éoliennes et les
panneaux solaires sont produits avec une
aciérie qui est faux cils une industrie
des métaux non ferreux qui est faux cils
de la chimie qui est faux cils des
transports qui sont faux cils et c'est
pour ça que ça coûte pas cher et de la
cimenterie qui est faux cils le jour où
on aura plus que des panneaux solaires
et des éoliennes pour faire tourner les
cimenteries les mines les hauts
fourneaux etc on parlera du prij pas sûr
que ça reste le même donc on pense
aujourd'hui que le prix marginal dans un
monde dopé aux combustibles fossiles
peut devenir un prix moyen dans un monde
qui en seraient dépourvus
ça reste à prouver pour le moment moi
j'en suis pas du tout convaincu dans les
autres énergies bas carbone pilotable
très intéressante vous avez nucléaire
vous avez l'hydroélectricité et dont on
parle trop peu dans les énergies
renouvelables bée qui n'est pas sans
inconvénient il faut quand même rappeler
que le barrage des trois gorges a
conduit à évaluer un million de
personnes c'est à dire cinq fois plus
qu'à tchernobyl
c'est un peu plus 4,8 pour sa création
donc les énergies renouvelables et que
quand on utilise du bois en trop grande
quantité ce à défaut reste donc les
énergies renouvelables ne sont pas
merveilleuses elles ont des avantages et
des inconvénients et jean revient
surtout au point principal c'est qu'on
ne fera pas fonctionné une humanité
industrielle de 8 milliards d'individus
avec juste des énergies d'accord par
exemple le gaz naturel qui est certes
une vraie synergie fossiles quelle est
sa place à long terme dans sa place à
long terme et les nuls comme aurait dit
monsieur kainz parce que le gaz reste
une énergie fossile et à long terme on a
droit à zéro énergie fossile si on veut
viser la neutralité que l'accord par
contre c'est une énergie qui peut être
intéressant à titre transitoire pour
supprimer du charbon est remplacée par
des centrales à gaz
mais jeudi bien que c'est à titre
transitoire alors aujourd'hui pour
toujours pour fixer les ordres de
grandeur les centrales à charbon c'est
20% des émissions planétaires
il faut tout les avoir fait régner dans
les 30 ans qui viennent
et bien tout la totalité si on veut
avoir la moindre chance
pété les deux degrés dont on parlait
tout à l'heure dans ce ferraillage des
centrales à charbon une petite partie
d'une petite partie peut être
transitoirement remplacé par du gaz une
petite partie pas la totalité sinon on
est au dessus d'accord évidemment cette
transition passe aussi par la régulation
c'est l'année prochaine on aura donc la
coop 26 à glasgow où l'ensemble des pays
et son c'est mettre à jour ses
engagements climatiques
qu'attendez vous de ces nouveaux
engagements et ce qu'on peut franchir
une marche intéressante sur ce chemin de
la transition écologique n'attends rien
du tout la seule coque qui a produit des
résultats vraiment intéressant depuis
l'histoire des kops et la cob de
copenhague 2009 que tout le monde est
unanimement qualifiée d'échec qui plonge
avec une histoire je vous raconterai
pour aujourd'hui parce que c'est trop
long mais en fait c'était pas du tout un
échec c'était un grand succès c'est la
seule coque qui a été un grand succès
parce que l'objectif politique des deux
degrés date de copenhague
d'accord pourquoi est ce que il ça a été
un grand succès parce que copenhague a
été une op à du g20 sur les nations
unies c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé
en pratique c'est à dire qu'à un moment
il ya une bande de chefs d'état qui sont
réunis dans un coin 10 ans peut pas
partir comme ça les mains vides et c'est
là qu'ils ont décidé les deux degrés
sinon la coop en régime ordinaire j'ai
envie de dire c'est un processus onusien
en remontant sa décide tout à
l'unanimité alors la coop c'est
exactement comme si vous prenez une
assemblée de 200 copropriétaires à qui
vous ne donnez pas de projet de
résolution où il n'ya pas de syndic où
il ya une voie par appartements quelle
que soit la superficie de l'appartement
mais où par contre les travaux sont à
payer au prorata de la surface et qui
sent encore des bijoux aux récents
syndic doit se mettre d'accord à
l'unanimité en l'espace d'une journée à
200 sur un programme de travaux qui
conduit en gros à tour et visiter de
fond en comble dans l'immeuble quelle
est la probabilité qu'ils y arrivent
donc la coop c'est exactement la même
chose
chacun arrive avec ce qu'il est prêt à
faire et pas donc c'est un endroit d'où
ne sortira aucun système contraignant
pour l'humanité c'est un système
remontant donc les pays ne font pas
entériner ce qu'ils étaient déjà prêts à
faire pour d'autres raisons que ce qui
se passe à la coop d'accord on voit
quand même beaucoup de mesures qui sont
mises en place au niveau peut-être
nationale ou régionale sur ce soit sur
le bâtiment sur les transports il ya
quand même des choses qui se produisent
l accès à ce jeu en fait ça se joue au
nid
dpi quand le pays et fédérales et très
grands comme les états unis ça se joue
au niveau des etam ça se joue au niveau
des entreprises ça se joue au niveau des
collectivités locales ça se joue au
niveau des particuliers mais ça ne se
joue pas malheureusement au niveau de la
coop
encore une fois où on ne fait
qu'entériner ce qui se passe déjà en ce
qui concerne l'europe
on est dans une situation très
particulière parce que
l'approvisionnement en combustible de
l'europe est déjà sous stress le pétrole
disponible en europe a baissé de 14 %
entre 2006 et 2010 9 et c'est parti pour
continuer tout simplement parce que la
production mondiale de pétrole sur le
pétrole conventionnel est passé par un
pic en 2008 et sur le pétrole non
conventionnel le shale oil gas et les
sables bitumineux probablement en 2018
le gaz disponible en europe et déjà la
baisse
orienté à la baisse depuis 2005 le
charbon disponibles en europe est
orienté à la baisse depuis la fin des
années 60
donc toutes les énergies fossiles sont
orientés à la baisse en europe qui va ou
pas clean a donc un de mes conclusions
moi c'est que l'europe étant le dos au
mur nous de toute façon on a tout
intérêt à se lancer à fond dans la
décarbonation parce que de toute façon
c'est ce qui va nous arriver
et si on attend les bras croisés que ça
nous arrive involontairement ça se
passera par une récession continue j'ai
envie de dire
et donc ça posera quelques petits sujets
d'organisation parce que là on la voit
jamais venir enfin un truc pour lequel
ils réalisent donc mon sentiment c'est
que il faut y aller il faut y aller
franco
malheureusement aujourd'hui l'europe ne
s'est pas organisé pour le faire de
manière cohérente elle poursuit encore
deux objectifs qu'ils se marchent sur
les pieds qui sont la base du nucléaire
et la baisse du co2 et dans les
politiques j'ai envie de dire appliquer
quand on regarde les détails à ce moment
où se rend compte qu'il ya plein de
trucs qui vont dans le mauvais sens
quand on regarde les réglementations
soient des pays pris isolément soit de
l'europe prise comme un taux d'accord
alors j'en reviens peut-être rôle de
l'investisseur tu peux faire un
investisseur aujourd'hui dans ce
contexte est encore une fois pour
favoriser cette transition écologique
comment doit-il que doit-il mettre en
place alors les deux premières marches
qui sont donc un investisseur à mon avis
il doit monter c'est un de bien
comprendre le problème qui est à traiter
parce que là on en a parlé un quart
d'heure mais en fait mon analyse
personnelle c'est qu'il faut plutôt 20
heures de coups pour finir par bien
comprendre le problème à traiter alors
bien comprendre ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire bien comprendre les données
physiques du problème quels sont les
constantes de temps les ordres de
grandeur les irréversibilité en classe
et des choses qui sont absolument
essentielles il faut bien comprendre
ensuite le lien entre l'énergie et
l'économie or aujourd'hui dans le monde
de l'investissement vous manipulez d
euros est trop de gens pensent que les e
ronde hier sont le meilleur élément pour
prédire les héros de demain
alors qu'en fait le meilleur élément
pour prédire les oraux de demain c'est
la fisk de demain et pas les héros
d'hier ça ça demande une un petit
quelques petites modifications dans la
batterie dans la trousse à outils qu'on
a l'habitude d'utiliser sa demande aussi
de la formation et la deuxième chose
qu'un investisseur doit faire c'est se
doter d'une métriques qui est
suffisamment granulaire pour être
capable d'opposer pour chaque action
unitaire la partie euros et la partie
carbone et ça si on est un peu sérieux
ça vous coûte quelques pour cent des
budgets informatiques d'accord très bien
alors je vois qu'on a on a reçu quelques
questions des participants à la
conférence donc je vais en profiter pour
peut-être vous reposer deux ou trois
donc vous avez abordé la question des
puits quelque part les puits naturels de
carbone
on a une question effectivement on a
assisté ces dernières années à des
incendies assez massif que ce qu'on
amazonie en californie encore vu cette
année
quel rôle pour tout cas quel est
l'impact direct de ce type d'événement
sur le coup la capacité alors il va
également il ya évidemment mauvais sens
c'est à dire qu'au moment où vous avez
un incendie vers le carbone qui était
dans les arbres par instantanément dans
l'atmosphère
vous avez d'autres phénomènes
d'affaiblissement des pluies qui ont
commencé à prendre place depuis le début
des années 2000 à cause d'un stress
hydrique avec les plantes ont besoin
d'eau pour pousser donc les arbres sont
tes plantes ont besoin d'eau pour tous
c'est à cause d'un stress hydrique qui a
tendance à s'intensifier aux moyennes
latitudes
vous avez une partie des forêts qui ce
parc qui se portent pardon de plus en
plus mal et qui donc n'a
exclu à compenser par la photosynthèse
les émissions de carbone des sols parce
que vous avez les branches mortes les
feuilles etc qui se décompose ça vous
fait des émissions de carbone et vous
avez les incendies qui viennent se
rajouter par dessus et donc il est
parfaitement possible malheureusement
que l'ensemble des écosystèmes
terrestres
d'ici à quelques décennies ne représente
plus du tout un puits c'est à dire
qu'elles ne soient plus du tout capable
d'absorber une partie des émissions
humaines mais devienne à son tour une
source
c'est à dire que à la faveur de
dépérissement des arbres à cause du
dépérissement des arts des incendies et
de la limitation de la photosynthèse et
bien les écosystèmes terrestres
deviennent eux aussi une source
d'émissions et non pas un puits est à ce
moment le processus commence à
s'emballer on sait pas trop où il
s'arrête d'accord on voit bien la
nécessité aussi de préserver des tier de
préserver les espaces naturels milliards
et aux siens oui alors naturel ou
entreprises et parce que par exemple en
france la totalité des forêts son
entreprise il ya plus de forêts
primaires en france mais on a un vrai
sujet sur la gestion forestière il faut
que c'est un sujet d'actualité en france
en ce moment puisqu'elle une réforme de
l'eau nf qui est inquiétant en
discussion on a un vrai sujet sur la
gestion forestière il faut absolument
d'abord évacué prioritairement les
arbres qui vont mourir de toute façon on
a un sujet avec les épicéas en plaine
par exemple en france nous commence à se
trouver dans des conditions qui sont
trop bas de l'hers le être en plein
également mourir donc césar il faut les
évacuer avant qu'il meure il faut les
remplacer par autre chose donc on a un
besoin massif d'investissement dans la
forêt voilà typiquement un domaine dans
lequel l'état devrait garantir des
rendements en france souffre déjà du
nucléaire est donc lourd ou l'éolien et
le solaire servent pas à grand chose
je préférerais que l'état garantisse les
rendements dans la régénération
forestière plutôt que dans la plantation
des éoliennes et panneaux solaires ça me
parait plusieurs d'accord je reviens à
un sujet joint une deuxième question sur
lie donc toujours aux énergies
renouvelables vous avez touché c'est un
petit peu du doigt tout à l'heure sur le
la question est de savoir quel est le
bilan réel du stockage de l'énergie en
l'occurrence énergies intermittentes
le bilan carbone réel quand on stocke
dans des batteries aujourd'hui les
énergies renouvelables avance avant
d'avoir un prêt de david en carbone en
après une sorte de grandeur quand vous
regardez aujourd'hui sur terre la
puissance de stockage installé sur terre
c'est à dire la quantité de dispositifs
qui peuvent prendre l'électricité sur le
réseau aux clientes quand il y en a trop
et là c est stocké alors pas sous forme
électricité parce qu'on peut pas stocker
l'électricité en tant que tel mais sous
d'autres formes en particulier en
remontant de l'eau en altitude dans les
barrages
la puissance de stockage disponible sur
terre ses deux puissants 2% pardon de la
puissance de production
on a un peu plus de 7000 gigawatts de
centrales électriques installées sur
terre on a un peu plus de 150 gigawatts
de puissance de stockage d'accord donc
cédé 2% et au sein de ses 2 % les
batteries représentent 0 5%
donc les batteries ça fait aujourd'hui
0,01 % de la puissance de production
électrique sur terre donc l'idée qu'on
va vivre dans un monde dans lequel il y
aura essentiellement des panneaux
solaires des éoliennes et des batteries
jeux aux enfants mourront qu'on y sera
toujours pas donc avant même d'avoir un
problème de bilan carbone on apprenne
d'ordre de grandeur on aura juste pas
assez de métal parce qu'une batterie
électrochimique
c'est de la métallurgie lien on aura
juste pas assez de métal pour être
capable de stocker des quantités
d'électricité significative est par
ailleurs le bilan carbone de la batterie
est pas nul puisque comme c'est de la
métallurgie il faut produire ces métaux
donc il faut réduire les oxydes ça émet
du co2 aujourd'hui stocker un
kilowattheure électrique sur batteries
juste la partie stockage appel par des
productions de l'électricité c'est entre
50 et 100 grammes de co2 par
kilowattheure d'accord ce qui veut dire
qu'un kilowattheure solaire stockée
restituer en france c'est plus de 100
grammes de co2 par kilowattheure donc
c'est pas c'est mieux que le gaz qui est
à 400 c'est mieux que le charbon qui est
habile c'est beaucoup moins bien que le
nucléaire qui est à six essais à zéro
d'accord donc c'est pas on n'est pas
dans la neutralité alors on n'est pas du
tout donc quand on dit le solaire et la
batterie c'est zéro co2 c'est pas vrai
d'accord très bien peut-être dernière
question est peut être aussi en forme de
conclusion
évidemment la question liée aux
conséquences de la crise kobe 19
est ce que ça peut jouer comme un
accélérateur cette transition écologique
ce qui est probable
en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai observé
autour de moi est ce que j'ai comme
retour d'une partie des gens à qui je
discute mais il faut se méfier parce que
qui se ressemble s'assemble donc je ne
suis pas du tout sûr que je discute avec
des gens qui sont représentatifs
donc parmi les gens avec lesquels je
discute le commis de 19 à agit un peu
comme un réveil matin c'est à dire qu'
une partie des gens se disent tiens les
mauvaises surprises c'est quand même
possible de temps en temps tout ne se
passe pas entre guillemets comme prévu
alors en fait c'est pas comme prévu
c'est tout comme souhaité parce qu'en ce
qui concerne le climat comme prévu c'est
plutôt que sa rivale d'accord donc c'est
tout ne se passe pas comme souhaité et
donc dans ce domaine où ça fait
maintenant un certain temps qu'on nous
annonce que
d'avoir des mauvaises surprises faudrait
peut être qu'on commence à s'en occuper
par ailleurs tant qu'à avoir arrêté une
partie des activités allaient redémarrer
derrière on se dit peut-être que ça
serait pas évoquée pas plus idiots
qu'autre chose qu'on lit redémarre de
façon un peu différente
alors c'est pas ce qui est en train de
se passer ou marginalement s'il est en
train de se passer mais
vraisemblablement que oui la crise du
covin 19 à dans un certain nombre de
consciences agit comme un accélérateur
de la nécessité de s'occuper un peu
sérieusement des limites planétaires
jean marc jancovici merci pour votre
participation aujourd'hui et votre
contribution très utile à ces sujets
fondamentaux
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
aujourd'hui pour cette conférence et
nous vous donnons rendez vous début 2021
sur un autre sujet
[Musique]